i've been using and testing apple's mac
safe battery pack
every single day for a week now and i
have to say it is one of the most
disappointing apple products in years
and i would only recommend it to two
groups of people in this honest review
i'll give you every positive and
negative you need to know and compare it
to three other magnetic battery packs
that in some cases
cost less than a third of the price are
smaller lighter and provide more charge
this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
i have to say that my favorite thing
about
apple's magsafe battery pack is just how
clean and simple
it looks the minimalistic matte white is
probably the best choice and it has
stayed surprisingly clean and clear of
scratches
even though i've been lugging it around
everywhere it's also pretty slim
compared to anchors but the other two
are just as slim
and are a little bit more grippy thanks
to their glossy backs
i do love that there is no power button
it just turns on and off automatically
when you attach or remove it
which is the convenience you get when
paying apple's prices
the same thing goes for the battery
level indicators which are non-existent
on the pack
like you get with other ones but instead
it just shows up in your iphone's
widgets
but both of those aren't really worth
paying the extra price for
in my opinion since in the last 9 months
i have never had a problem pressing a
button when attaching a different
wireless back
and having those leds on the back isn't
that bad
in fact i probably prefer overall since
you don't have to turn on your phone
or even have the pack attached to see
what the battery's charge is at
by the way i have links to all of the
packs that i'll mention plus a few more
down in the video description below
build quality wise apple's pack
is top notch the plastic feels premium
the silicone on the back
is nice and it doesn't attract lint but
this is where the first of the four big
disappointments come
in along with one of them which is the
deal breaker for me
personally and for a lot of you four out
of the five third-party battery packs
that i've purchased
don't hold on to my iphone as well as
i'd like and i was hoping that apple's
genuine pack would do much better
just like their wallets hold on much
better than the third party options
but nope that doesn't mean that it will
randomly fall off
but it does twist very easily which was
my biggest complaint about kickstand
and if you press on the power button and
you're not gripping your phone well
it will come off how can this 28 blue
mini
have a stronger connection and way
better grip than apple's 99
genuine pack well that's where we start
getting into actual performance instead
of just good looks and branding
right after i think our sponsor
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience
it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio blog ecommerce or
anything else you simply choose a
template customize blocks of text and
images and easily move them around
it's incredibly simple affordable and rs
have been running flawlessly for years
now
bringing in tons of traffic thanks to
its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card needed by going to
squarespace.com
maxtec or by using the custom link down
below and when you're ready to launch
you will save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain the thing that stumped people the
most was how it had such a small
1460 milliamp hour battery pack where
most packs like anker
and our kickstand charger which yes i
call it that because as a kickstand
offer 5 000 milliamp hours and our super
small
blue mini offers 4200 well it turns out
the apple was really focused on
efficiency
and because of that they used double the
voltage to give us a real world
2 920 milliamp hour rating as well as
having
more efficient chips and coil compared
to third-party brands
but unfortunately even with its
efficiency which i'll show you
wasn't enough to make it competitive on
the plus side
this thing charges very fast compared to
anchor's pack
because of its small battery and because
it accepts 15 watts of power if you use
a 20 watt adapter and a usb type-c
cable neither of which are included in
the box another major plus is that you
can use it as a pass-through charger or
basically a wireless charging pad which
the only other one that could do this
is anchor but since this is maxi you can
get up to 15 watts of wireless charging
if you use it this way
compared to 5 watts when you do that it
will charge both your phone
and the bank at the same time but at a
slower pace than charging one or the
other
unless you use at least a 35 watt
adapter
which i'll link to one down below if you
want the quickest charging possible
if you're using a 20 watt charger it
will take about 40 percent slower to
charge
unless the pack or the phone is
pre-charged now personally i'm not a fan
the apple chose to use a lightning port
it doesn't make sense if you only want
to bring one cable with you
and it does allow for easy wireless
charging
but this is where the next two biggest
downsides come in because of the
lightning port you can't send power back
the other way
like you can with usb type-c so if you
want to use
wire charging at some point say to
charge your apple watch or to charge
your iphone
much faster and get more capacity you
can't do that like you can with other
packs and if you want to have lightning
for convenience the kickstand charger
has both
a lightning port and usb type-c for
charging
and then you can actually get power
through the usb type-c port
with a good amount of wattage as for
reverse wireless charging
yes it works but it is incredibly slow
if you plug in your lightning cable into
the bank itself you will have a full
charge
in one hour and 15 minutes or two hours
if it is also charging your phone at the
same time but if you plug the cable into
your phone
it will take five hours to reverse
wirelessly charge
the battery bank and the other thing is
reverse wireless charging won't
work if your phone is charging i only
saw it kick in once my phone stopped
charging
so that five hours is with a fully
charged iphone
that means it will take you seven hours
to fully charge both your phone
and the bank reversely if you have a 20
watt
charger into your iphone 12 compared to
3 hours and 15 minutes
if you just decide to plug it into the
pack itself and attach your phone
in addition you can't use anything but
an iphone 12 series phone
to reverse wirelessly charge this pack
so if you have a wireless charging pad
a magsafe puck or even one of the three
in one magsafe stands that have that
little base
you cannot use it to charge this you
will start having to use a lightning
cable like you did before
and that's not even the worst or most
annoying thing about it
let's get into the charging performance
and major limitations
for my testing i use an iphone 12 which
is by far the most popular new
iphone but the 12 pro should charge
exactly the same since it has the same
battery
and i will also comment on the 12 mini
and the 12 for max in just a little bit
i made sure the iphone 12 was completely
drained and attached each battery
to see how long they would take to turn
your phone back on
and the name brands were a fair bit
quicker compared to the third party
options
after 15 minutes apple's magsafe hit
nine percent
better than blue mini which only hit six
percent but slightly behind anchor at 10
and kickstand managed 12 at the 30
minute mark
all chargers about double their charge
rate with the blue mini hitting
13 max eighth at 18 anchors still higher
at 19 and kickstand at 23
so as you can see we were right in our
first video about this charger
when you're using it as a wireless
powered pack it provides nowhere near 15
watt max safe speeds
which is the biggest reason so many of
us were waiting for
and willing to pay extra for it i tested
all of them using an
app that actually measures how much
wattage is captured by the battery
and apple's is slightly lower than
anker's better than blue mini
but still behind other third options
that can charge wirelessly at up to 7.5
watts
let's skip over 45 minutes and jump
straight to the one hour mark
and apple's pack hits 36 percent the
blue mini is slower at 28
and kickstand is much higher at 42
but the other chargers have another
advantage jumping into the one and a
half hour mark which is where wired fast
charging would have fully charged the
iphone 12
apple's magsafe pack hit 53 and just
15 minutes after that the pack was
completely drained
charging our iphone to 57 at that time
inger was slightly ahead but still had
power
and kickstand reached a much higher 68
our smallest and slowest charger reached
the same amount as magsafe
about 15 minutes later but it kept going
until 68
and the other two kept charging for
another 30 minutes
until they hit 87 and 95
so apple's charger is only faster than
the much smaller and cheaper blue mini
charger
but the charge capacity is far lower
than all the third-party options
apple's pack is also more efficient but
doesn't really matter if it can only
provide 57
charge with an iphone 12 or 44
with the 12 pro max and even the mini
with a tiny battery only charges
79 of it now i know that some of you
will say that you don't need a full
charge from it
you just want to maintain your iphone's
battery while you're using it
and just pull from the external one kind
of like you did with apple's old battery
cases
well that's the last disappointment this
thing is very sensitive to heat
maybe because apple is being sensitive
to battery longevity
or maybe because heat will make the tiny
battery in it die super quickly
and give you barely any charge although
the previous charge percentages were
when i wasn't using the phone and it was
in a cool room
when you're using it and there's
anything that is pushing the phone the
battery won't charge
even though the logo shows up in my
previous video i
shared that the battery pack wasn't
charging when i was gaming and the
battery drained from 100 to 90
and 30 minutes of gaming while anchors
held the battery
i did the same test again but i started
at 50
battery to make sure that there weren't
any charging limitations
and after 30 minutes of call of duty the
battery dropped to 36 percent
and the pack barely changed in its
capacity anker
kept the battery at the same charge and
the phone only lost two percent when
using the blue mini charger
that has a slower charge speed this
isn't with gaming
exclusively other tougher apps caused
the maxi pack to stop
charging as well and yesterday i was out
on the boat
and the battery pack was not charging my
phone even though it wasn't super hot
out
and there was also a breeze going now i
understand battery longevity but if i
were to plug a cable into my phone
it would still charge during these times
even
if that meant that it would get hotter
so taking everything into account
this thing cost a hundred bucks and has
way too many limitations compared to
third-party options
that provide more charge are way more
flexible and smaller
and cheaper so basically because of this
i'm returning
two out of the three packs that i bought
the two that work for my own personal
use
and i'm gonna be keeping this one in the
office just because i need to for future
references
and for those of you out there i would
say most people should not buy one
as well the only two groups that i think
might still want to buy it are those who
don't care about performance
at all unless you want to buy something
that is named brand that they know that
will last a long time
but personally with that said i'd rather
use this and maybe in a year or two have
to buy a new one
and it'd still be way less than this or
those of you guys that don't
yet have a wireless charging pad and
you're gonna use this for dual purpose
both as a wireless pass-through charging
pad and at the same time an extra bank
as well
in that case that does make it a better
value but
overall i am just not so thrilled with
apple's pack but you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comments
section below
click that circle above if you guys
enjoyed this video you want to see more
like it that will help us reach our goal
of a million subscribers before the end
of the year this is max and i will see
you
in the next video